So I had one of the great surprises in my life on Friday after coming back to my office after class.
Top of my desk was was a copy of hints for referees that I had mentioned in class that we were searching high and low for.
And so now you have it as a handout. And it's not all that great, but it's not too bad.
And it turned out that that Jack Snake, who was a student in his class, had received a copy of this from John Hershberger,
who graduated this year, and John probably received it from somebody else and some other student.
And so I could pass down. So this is a ense generation copy for some in and I don't even recognize the style of commas in this writing.
So I'm not sure that it's mine. But it's but it's close to what I what I wrote in the 60s, I think.
And so it summarizes the main the main points that I said on Friday.
Still, I want to I want to belabor them by going by talking still some more about refereeing today and giving some more examples.
Let's see some other announcements, I guess, first. Here we are in November and November 18th is one of the big deadlines that you
should all remember that I would like we would like you to turn in a rough draft,
which is the closer it is to the final draft, the better, because you get better feedback then.
But this will this what you're turning on November 18th should be a what you call it,
a beta test or something or a preliminary version of what you or what you plan to do afterwards.
But we can give you this feedback before it's too late. No, before.
I mean, we're going to get some some response back to you after that.
It take us a little time integrated, of course. But the final day of I'm not sure exactly the day.
When did we ever tell you when the term papers are actually due in December?
Well, it's sort of like when whenever this class would normally have had its final exam, it would be the day.
Now we have another guest lecturer coming in December on December 7th.
This is Rosalie Stemmer who who has taught copy editing at Stanford in the past and is teaching it at Berkeley, at Berkeley.
And I told her and she's a copy editor for The Chronicle. And even though garbage shop is scheduled to come to the summit meeting on December 7th,
she's got somebody to take her place at the Chronicle that day. And she'll come here and give and give a talk.
And I'll ask you to give the best 50 minutes of her class at Berkeley copyediting.
And we'll all be in copy editing mode by that time, since the term papers will be due soon.
So that's that's probably number six in the total of guest lectures in the quarter.
Rosalie Stemmer Stemmer.
As in the No.
Something this has only one aim anyway. You might say shamer if you were a German.
Another funny thing crossed my desk on Friday afternoon.
I was telling you about people who who makes the order of eminent when they go from alphabetical order.
And so here's a formula that I think is rather rather remarkable in emphasizing the community.
Or don't you think that's remarkable? Nobody's laughing. I mean, I thought this was hilarious.
This is something that I would have written with and in natural order in all cases.
But somehow or other, he doesn't get what?
Well, this is modification of energy. Yeah. Yeah, yeah. Right.
Yeah. This is an amazing thing that he found, by the way, for those with interests in mathematics, is that this you take this product here,
Alpha, the golden ratio and plus Route five over to and you you you form this product and it's and it's associative.
It just there's no no way it should really be associative. I mean,
it's there's this rounding error round to need to take the floor up there and then multiply
these together to two is to approximate results and then and then do that again on this sum.
It's not distributed, but it's also it's associative. It's it's incredible. Part I it was wonderful.
I was going to spend an hour last night proving that, proving that it was associative. And five hours later I decided to give up.
But I believe it. I proved that another operation was associated that I like better.
So I wrote to him about it. Well, now. Refereeing her mentioned the.
The paper that I that I wrote under an assumed name in order to get it because I had the chance to since I knew it, he was the editor.
I knew that he could send it out for refereeing without without giving my my my name on the paper.
Now, some journalists actually do blind referee. They they cover up the author's name and I think one of the ace H.M.S. journals.
Does this cover up the author's name when it goes to the referee so that the referee isn't supposed to just say, oh,
yes, so-and-so really knows his stuff and I'll just pass it without even without even looking at it and somebody else.
Some unknown. I never heard of. So what right do they have to publish anything?
You know, there is a there is some influence.
Sociologists have found that there is some influence on the names of papers when you're when you're reviewing them.
I mean, they did an experiment. I read about some years ago. And I believe that it's that it was reported correctly.
Oh, you can't believe everything you read in the paper that they took that they took like 5th and 6th grade papers that were written in English.
And they and they had them graded by two different groups.
And in one case, they just changed the name on the paper.
Somebody somebody whose name was with us was changed from Herbet to Sam or something like this.
And in the end, they found that they were getting a definite full grade difference.
I mean, certain people with certain names who were just we got to see instead of a B, the identical paper.
And it was it was consistent, very strong. Typical correlation now.
So people seem to be influenced by their preconception as to whether what are paper is going to be like just by the author's name.
It's a major thing. But it seems to be true. Now, I.
I chose in this case a name that was based.
I mean, anybody who who reads Agatha Christie would realize that, you know, and this is a this is a pending from from the what is it called the.
And then there were none. But I made it, Ursula.
You just you know, in order to try to get extra discrimination.
I mean, certainly a white woman has no right to publish anything deep in computer science.
Right. And. Well, I don't know.
Anyway, I. So. So we did this.
And I got to explain some of the background for this, because this tape, this was dated July eighty one.
Here's a here's a letter I wrote in April. Eighty one. It says, Dear Bruce, I was surprised to find my paper was accepted with no referees reports.
Anyway, I reviewed it myself and found that it needed to be improved.
And so, you know, I started having to get my own referees where I would where I wrote to, you know, I well,
typically I also will send to people that I think are are knowledgeable in the field anyway, because I think they might be interested in a pre-print.
And so I had to wait. But anyway, I got so. So here I sent a paper and, you know, I got a postcard back saying it will appear in such and such issue.
Well, that's not that's not good for me.
Here's the letter I got from from my man.
And you said UCLA. Who? Who?
I sent the revised version of my paper. And he so he re it and he made more comments.
So he gave me a referee report. In other words, after even after I had had sent this revised edition, I made more corrections on galley proofs.
I had to I had to go do this myself.
Literate programing. I showed you that article about literate programing and the Computer Journal.
So I got back. He says, thank you.
In closing your paper there, a program and I shall be delighted to include this in the Computer Journal at the earliest opportunity.
I know referee report on that. And also, I sent out paper to Two Worth and and Dykstra and Knauer and got no answer from them either.
They don't have time to read that kind of stuff. So. So that particular paper I had no feedback on at all had it his take take my chances.
It could have been better with I. I'd had somebody looking over and saying, Don, work harder.
This was the report that I got on the on the paper that was submitted by Ursula and.
Well, it's generally it's it's something that helped me to.
To look at it, to see the detail, I just want to show you the idea and suggestion of corrections.
So here pointing out a gap in my exposition that I had just given letters, LW D.G,
without any without any comment as to why as to why those letters are appropriate and suggest here they call it something like that.
I'm not sure what dng mean anyway. And then similarly here. So. So in other words, this was a good, good suggestion.
Improve the exposition. Here I have feedback from a motivated reader.
What more can you want before you publish something and see what you swing?
The question that people are going to ask here. Here are no technical typographical error.
I had five instead of a four subscript missing variable mis named, and now here he had a change.
And here it's wrong. I mean, I said no here. I mean, it is my own writing here.
It turned out that that he he thought this should be should be this.
He's wrong. But still, there was a reason why he thought it was wrong.
So I had to add some other sentence to make to clarify that, that this is sort of a sick you know,
that this really is this way, even though you might think something else. So I had to. So. So that caused me, even though the referee is wrong.
And I, in fact, had a few more places here. And here it says, in fact, I made a comment to myself, this was a bug in my first draft.
And I. He's he's so simple for his.
He's doing something which seems it seems right. But it turns out to be wrong.
When you when you when you look at it, it's kind of subtle and so now.
But I realized that I ought to add, Mark, more explanation in the paper at that point.
OK. So so when you get a referee report, also you even when the referee is wrong, the moral is.
He was he was not the only person in the world who's gonna read that and make the same wrong conclusion.
In fact, he's the kind of person that you probably are hoping most to reach in your article.
So you want to add a little redundancy to so that so that the reader will understand that.
OK. This one here's another one that comes from eighty one the same year when I was having trouble finding finding referees.
Well here I got a good one because I, I went to a journal. No theory.
It's a it's a highly specialized journal.
And again, I'm, I'm an outsider. I'm not ordinarily that's not my my my fault.
My, my work is number three. I just happen to solve the problem. And the number theory is proposed.
And I so I wanted to to submit to the proper journal.
But now here says the main result of a simple formula which the proof is not very complicated, not unlikely.
The result is already known. In fact, I mean, there's millions of number of theories in the world.
And but I haven't been able to spot it in the literature, nor has it been able to find anyone able to answer that question.
When the people he's asked for, I'm submitting it hopes that your referees will know the true story well.
So I know I'm here. I am in eighty one trying my best to to encourage and get a good referee report because
I've been having these experiences weren't we're always refereeing my my work anymore.
But now you might also say that I'm exploiting the system.
I mean here I am, you know, I'm, I'm too busy to look, go to the library and look and look this up,
you know, and what if everybody would do this and let the referees do all the work?
You know, this is this kind of a lazy approach? Well, no, I don't think I mean here.
I mean, I made a serious check. I talked to I talked to two leading people.
I mean, I looked as it came with the literature and such such things as very best.
And the only way to really solve information retrieval problems on technical results
being new is really to go to the people who are the world authorities on this stuff.
And that and those people that's part of their their service of the world is to be a world authority on that thing.
I mean, you're going to be a world authority on something, too,
and people are going to want, you know, going to come to you and you're going to know this. And that's the only way really to do it.
No, no, no perfect indexing system to find this material.
And and so it's a cooperative effort and it takes place.
I think it's one of the ways in which which is one of the one of the nice ways in which science advances in cooperation
through through correspondence as well as through working in the same lab for a certain salary or something like this.
You know, this was something that we do as a joint enterprise. And and it works as long as there aren't enough, you know, a lot of dumb cluck.
So spoiling it. And I you can imagine all kind of scenarios in which this kind of system would break down, but it does tend to work.
So what's your estimate, your subjectivism probability that the result has to exist before you resort to that?
What do you mean? I'm sorry that the result has to exist.
So, you know, if you think that there's an 80 percent chance that this result doesn't exist.
I think it's if I think it is that it's almost certainly well known.
Then I would then I would probably you know, I'll I'll give it a good shake to find out.
I mean, there, you know, I know how to use a library. And I. And there's stuff and there's histories of number theory.
Dixon's history of number three, for example, three volumes that that went through Taoism and thousands of papers and gives them in capsule form.
And so you can look there and find all kinds of all kinds of stuff.
But, you know, you craft as and as you grow, all you learn who where you might naturally find something on some results and other ones,
like I wrote a letter to Levak about a number to see if somebody wants to surprise me with something on my office desk after class today.
There's a there's a theorem that we had in that we had on an old exam.
It was it was this is the greatest integer which you call the floor of M X one plus
plus M X in is equal to the greatest thing with some of the greatest integers,
X for all M X will x1 through X and R and R real numbers and M.
And this is supposed to happen for hold for all in four. So this is for all M integers m if and only if at most one of the X's is an integer.
But one x x K is an integer now.
And we heard this on the final exam once and I and in this book I'm writing concrete math.
I want to give credit to where this came from.
And when the teachers gave the answer to the final exam, they said they got this problem from the math monthly.
And I looked through the math monthly problems.
I spent about 10 hours so far looking through all the previous issues, starting in nineteen seventy two.
Going back, I got back to about 1963 and all the problems in the math once and didn't see it.
Now Miss Muncie has been published since 1890.
So I know know and I wrote this, I wrote to Scott Drysdale who who is the P.A. and he said he doesn't remember,
but he did remember that it was from the monthly stored somewhere in his math magazine.
And so that's interesting.
But so if anyway, so I wrote to no theories actually that they knew or where the result is, they said here, that's a neat result.
I never saw it before. Sounds pretty interesting. So I got that letter today saying they don't know.
So I can't retrieve haven't been able to retrieve it. OK.
So the main thing is, though, you should give it a reasonable shot, not just be real, real sloppy about this and let let everybody else do the work.
And, you know, I put in a lot of time reviewing other people's papers, and this is my chance to get some some of their time back.
You know, it's only fair. And as I say, it makes the science advance bit better to do it this way now.
So I got a letter back from the editor and he said, I've sent it to a referee and also read it himself, have a few minor comments.
And he makes so he he gives me feedback right away. And then he says.
But the question whether it's no have to be answered by someone better acquainted with the literature. And so he sends to a referee.
Now he gives me these comments here and here. Here he corrects typographical errors in the paper.
And then. And these are I mean, I'm guilty of that.
I should have I should the proof read the paper better or I send it to him.
Oh, here's one thing. No, he says one could give a stronger result than here.
He gives an error. He gives it so. So he says, why not give a stronger resolve?
I gave an error like two to the minus end.
And he says there's this irrational number defined by this equation, which my argument will still prove a stronger result than the point is that I,
I knew that that I could prove a stronger result, that I didn't think it was anywhere near best possible.
So I thought that for the expiratory purpose, there was no point in giving the best error that I could get from my method,
which I thought was was was was was sort of weak anyway.
The main idea was to get some kind of an error term, but not not the best possible.
And unless I had a much sharper method that I was using.
So but it proved that he read the paper. I mean, he was. So this is this is an.
Of what I would think. George Poyer would call a facile generalization.
There's there's there's two kinds of ways to generalize the results. One is one is what he calls soft.
And one is what he calls hard or something like this one. And there's that.
There's the kind that you can generalize by just looking at the argument, changing nothing but just but just seeing how.
What what. Look, that same argument will support if you if you know, what action does it really depend on and you define those actions and so on.
Anybody can go through that sort of sort of like a machine and and generalize the result.
But then there's a tendency. But it's I think it's.
Yeah. Let's see now. Susan, in the preface to problems and solving problems and solutions in in analysis, the one that her book mentioned.
It's a wonderful quote, actually.
And this is a similar comment like that in in his book on patterns of plausible inference like that, how to solve it.
That's the short book. I don't think it's in there anyway.
This is a facile generalization that has.
And but then there is but and this is what the editors supplied there, which I did.
But I didn't believe that it was worth it in this case to do it.
Sometimes it is. Then there's the real generalization where you find a pattern that's of significance.
And then you and you and you give it a proper name and terminology and you and then you develop a theory for it.
Now that those are much harder to come by. And those are that's real mathematics.
I don't know how. Now, I got the referee report back then from some of from the editor, and it came June eighty two.
So we apologize about how long it took and any quotes from the referee report.
So it's strictly related to some deep results of earlier session Kiran.
And later, these here are the main references and he gives the formulas that that are that are related and and so on.
But the results aren't the same. So so we're talking about similar problems, but not but not identical.
So Lexar was he he found this this referee found found some some papers that I'm sure
would be very difficult for me to retrieve in a million years in these you know.
Here we go. Nineteen fifty eight. There's one of these is one of thousands of math journals and so on.
The title called Remarks on the Theory of Diamantina Approximation. I mean.
No, no. No clue in the title what's exactly in it. But here we found through the referee's help, though irrelevant for reference now.
And then he said then the referee says he looked carefully there and he didn't find a thing closer.
But he suggests that I ask Irish or better yet, sprints, look who is acquainted with Russian literature.
If you want to make absolutely sure, do you want me to do this? You know?
And so and so I said, yes.
But he said, you know, if you were interested in speeding publication or being sure.
The existing literature. Well. Well, it turned out I said go ahead, ask sprints and.
And meanwhile, some some Dutch mathematicians using the using my paper were were able to generalize the result,
sharpen the message and get a much, much, much stronger theorem which got published before my my 28th printed.
But I still wanted to say I still wanted to, you know, to know Mike, Mike Margaret was simpler and I got I got a weaker result,
but it was turned out by using stronger methods because stronger result.
But that's OK. Still nice to know simple methods once in a while.
So finally, he says, I finally heard from Springsure who finds the results in your paper quite interesting and new and recommends, quote, publication.
So it's finally getting published. Here's the November eighty two. And so that did get put.
That didn't get published then. And OK, now here's another one, a recent a recent referee report.
This was July five. And so it is this in order here?
OK. Well, yeah, I guess so.
Yeah. So I don't see sure. The letter. But anyway, I, I had previously worked with this editor and I got a.
And I've got a terrific referee report from him on a previous previous thing, so I.
So here I'm complimenting him saying, boy, you found a terrific referee on his paper of mine.
I revised it. And since the referees comments led to considerable improvements in the expedition results, you may want to run it by him or her again.
The last section in particular has been completely rewritten. On the other hand, I did try to check his results carefully.
So I won't mind if you decide to save time before forwarding it directly to the printer.
The thing is, in this case, this is one of the examples I wanted to show you where the referee actually improve the theorem and and remain anonymous.
And, you know, just just as part of the Cooperative Enterprise of Journal Publishing says,
here's a here's a theorem that ought to be published in this paper of Kunoth,
even though, you know, even though he's you know, he's got this good result.
Now, if he were real, just jealous of his own, of all of his own work, he would he would go and publish his own paper about this thing.
But that's not typically the way it's done.
And so here's here's the report.
And in fact, I had to referee for this one, but this one was by some master.
I have no idea who it is. Of course, maybe if I studied the typewriter, I could I could I could work it out.
But here it suggests if there is an easy proof to a remark I made,
it should be given because he tried to verify and it took it took awhile and and I don't remember the details of that.
But now here's where here's what I'm talking.
Meyer says, It seems to me that if we have such a stone so this is a paper encoding theory, we can always construct a scheme that that does it.
And so he gives them a brand new construction,
which generalizes a special case that I that I had for four H equals three or four, something like that.
And and his argument is very nicely worked out combinatorial here.
So he he gives me this this this nice way of know sort of a geometric pattern that I hadn't had.
I didn't realize this way of looking at the problem he gives me.
The geometric pattern is sort of us as a way of blocking lines when every every way of going
from going through here has to cross through one of these dots or something like that.
He had a real nice argument there. And so he saw I was really glad, of course,
to get a referee report like that because it allowed me to take my special case for H equals three or four,
which or eight or whatever it was, and and show a general construction.
And so then at the end of the article, I, of course,
added an acknowledgment for several PIN trading observations that substantially improved this paper.
I guess I should have been even more explicit the when the thing came out in print.
Arthur, this thing and I'm sure I read several crediting that substantially improved this correspondence.
And by the way, the editors, the referees that I trickily are terrific, but they're copyeditors aren't aren't that good.
But they. But this was OK, I thought.
But but, you know, technically speaking, this one in the correspondence part of the journal rather than the paper is part of the journal.
And somebody asked about that on Friday. That's why I brought this here. Somebody said, what about letters section?
Well, these are certainly the referees. Also, they're just shorter. And so they put him in under correspondence.
But it's a it's a little bit funny, too, because it's actually a one to one correspondence that I was talking about in hand.
And so I, I said I've got to use corresponds to a double meaning and which is very nice.
But I told you I told you a few weeks ago that this journal I Tripoli on the journal
coding theory has a way of doesn't use apostrophes when they say zeros and ones,
I. This was something we were in the midst of some other discussion, but I wanted to read.
So people used to work when when people used to talk about the 50s,
they used to say apostrophe five zero apostrophe s first apostrophe for leaving out the
19 second positive fee for making it a genitive because that's belonging to the no no.
Feel sorry for forming the plural of of a symbol. The second second apostrophe was the form of a plural of a symbol to make fifties.
OK, so now the both apostrophes are left out in the 80s and and even in the 80s when we talk about the 50s and accepting the Palo Alto weekly,
a few weeks ago, they talked about the passage of.
60S, they left out the second of us.
We've been on the first more often, people leave out the first and not the second, but they're both going off now.
Typically and still, when you're front, when you're forming a plural of other things like you,
you dot the I's and cross the T's, you and you, you have to talk about A's and B's in a formula or something like that.
Still usually put the put the apostrophe in.
And I said at the time that I didn't think the I Tripoli transactions on Nation Theory,
which talks about coding all the time and zeros and ones all over the place.
I didn't think that they that they put apostrophes in when they gave a plural of zero.
Well, what I hadn't remembered because I looked back at this paper that they actually spell it out.
Zeros and ones ze are.
Oh, yes. And I believe that's wrong. I mean, they're copyeditor just even though they work with it all the time.
You're talking about a zero as a symbol, not as a not as a number.
And I believe the right rule is that you spell out a small number if it's used as a number, but not if it's used as a as a symbol.
And I don't have the example of the page here, but on the galley, proof that there was a put it came up where, where, where, you know,
it just made made the thing very ambiguous because here's the word one in the sentence and one is
also a pronoun that that is used in English to mean one doesn't does this or something like this.
And so. Or, you know, this one or something.
So I couldn't. So I had to rewrite several sentences because of this.
Well, it was perfect. I was referring to it, you know, changes zero to a one or something.
I mean, what percentage would have made perfectly good sense if it had shown as a symbol, but otherwise it looks like it looked like SEMICON.
So I did. So I accepted the word unity for one.
Now, now this is often done in mathematical writing. You know,
you say as as as X approaches unity or something like this or the radius is unity because they find out that if you say one in those contexts,
it it reads funding it because one has this multiple meanings. And if you can use the symbol one, you're better off than having to say unity,
which is funny, which is a sort of a funny mathematical convention just to get around this.
This is true. Well, enough is enough about that. OK.
Now let's see. Here's another comment in a paper that came out.
Let's see. This one says the title.
This would have had an interesting comment from a referee. It was a title is Ambiguous Without a hyphen, optimal font caching.
But hyphenation may not be appropriate. My favorite hyphenation problem.
This is what I liked about it appeared in a technical paper where the author wrote about common sense amplifiers.
And I think he needed a common sense amplifier to write this correctly as a common sense amplifier.
Here now with the present title.
I was very interested in learning about optimal fonts and found no discussion about the Danimal to the time or optimal font.
Caching is not clear or a sufficient number of font caches around to be interested in it.
But in fact, there are. But in any event, the ambiguity issues, presently, authors are free to find a suitable way to correct the problem.
And so we changed the title of the paper based on this, too.
To introduce another word prepaying, which is actually for.
This is Transaction's on programing languages and systems. So systems people know the word paging.
And this is the this is this is actually a keyword that we should have had in the title anyway.
And so anyway, now this this was otherwise a fairly lightweight referee report.
They didn't they didn't dig into some of the problems in the paper that they could have.
But look at this. It's this thoroughly. This is not.
Now, here's the other the other referee report we got. So I'm going to give the impression that you always get one.
Only one report, you know, depends on the journal you submit to as to how many referees they typically do.
And when I was an hour or when I was editor,
I would sometimes get get only one free report if I thought that that one that one would be sufficient because of the subject matter.
Something like that. Or if it was more controversial or a longer paper or something more or something, I don't.
But here is another. Another report that I got and here it had all kinds of references to.
To what the referee thought were were relevant references and well, in my opinion, again, this these these references were not relevant.
And I and I looked to look them over again to double check my my opinion on this.
And so I finally decided probably not to cite most of these because they they were talking about a different problem.
And still, it's you know, it's an honest mistake that you have to realize other readers are going to make.
Now, the paper itself I brought with me because I wanted to show you the it starts to answer the question of how to make it,
how to describe a complicated algorithm with sort of.
I was going to say,
how can you get across the feeling of a complicated algorithm by giving giving traces of the way it runs or something like that for the.
I said talk about animation of algorithms the other day. Takes a lot of work to do that.
But, you know, can you get the effect across in a journal article,
read it and somebody actually playing with this, playing with an act or going ahead and implementing.
Where are we? Well, this is one of the more extensive examples that I did of trying to understand to present this.
And so let me give you a little background on this.
What this paper is now, I was working on typesetting and we and we have a manuscript has come off that that has been processed by tech.
And now we have to take. We have to take it onto a machine that has a small memory for storing its fonts.
So we have to we have a big, big computer and we have a small typesetting machine.
It's not the typesetting machine can store about a hundred characters in its memory at any one time.
And so so the big machine is supposed to, you know, cache these things.
In other words, they're supposed to decide which hundred characters are in this machine.
And periodically it says, forget character number 30 to replace it by the following character.
And and the question is to try to do this in the optimum way so that now we have the whole the whole manuscript in front of us.
And so weak. And we have time at the end of every line to to change a few characters while the machine is backing is is moving its motors around.
And so you have time an on line, you know, thirty eight of a page to load five characters.
A bold face that we're going to need on line 50. And and so, so this is prepacked.
This is called pre paging in the sense of operating systems which would say that if you if you had time and you knew that a user was,
you know, in a few minutes was going to want a certain page from the desk to be present in memory, you could bring it in.
Now, maybe, you know, if this was was was idle instead of demand paging,
which is waiting until somebody demanded the page and then and then stop and work out some other some other job.
And then resume when you got it.
So so we. So we have the whole text of the of the manuscripts in our you know, we know the future.
Unlike the operating system, people who doesn't know maybe what the user is going to do unless the user has has some, you know,
is using a sequential file or something, we might want to know that he's going to bring in the next the next record.
In this case, we know the future. We know what characters are going to be coming up on line 60, even when we're doing line 30.
And so so that's what this paper is about,
trying to to say when you have time to bring in a limited number of of things which are the best ones to bring in.
And can you prove that they're often on the same side? Now, how do you explain the effectiveness of the of such an algorithm?
That is. And so we go through a long present day and then we give algorithms here.
As I mentioned, I start I I've been using a Pascal like style with a sort of a web indication.
Also, we're presenting algorithms in in these complications now.
But how do you so you presented the algorithm. We proved correct.
And we showed some certain kinds of optimality. But now we've got empirical tests.
We wanted to make we want to test it in practice.
And and so so I discussed the models that we used in the end.
And the sample, the samples that we did with it. It really has to be done unary on a realistic job.
And you can. Something like this. No.
No random model is it is appropriate.
Things are too complicated. You you want to really discuss it on on something that's typical of real life.
And so what I did was I gave like an A.
So I constructed a test file consisting of five pages which look which which do a lot of different kinds of typesetting.
And here was page one and it was page two. This was based on excerpts of of volume two of the art of computer programing.
Actually, this sample comes from the test pages that I made when I was designing tech, I.
I went through volume two and I. And I. And on page one, I copied a lot of it.
And then I got the stuff that I like that I already knew how to do.
So then I went to page fifty or something like this where there was an algorithm and every and every time something new came along,
a different aspect of typesetting. Then I would then I would say, how should I write this in tech?
And I'm designing tech as I'm doing this. I mean, this this was also this turnout was also my my test.
This particular page was actually the test case that I that I used as a sitting down over one night, two nights singing out with the tech language.
Should be I'm trying to say how what what kind of a source language would I like to generate these pages?
And and then I then I, I had the source language and I said, OK, now implement it.
And and then actually after I implemented a year later, I used this page also for testing.
And then we tested it on. So I had this file around sort of as an example of all kinds of different typographic conventions.
So here you get to the bottom of page one.
And then all of a sudden at the top of page two, you got you got nine point caps coming in, even though you've been working in ten point size type.
And so you have to bring in all these caps. But before you get to the end of page one and so on.
And there's tables and row with all these different things that are coming in here, made a fairly good, good example of a test of a test program.
And and it continues on here. So it has math formulas and quite a variety of different different things can happen.
What is this? Three three, three three. This subsection doesn't exist. Trialing.
Well, anyway, this was this was a good idea.
So now how do we describe how well the method works? Well,
so I describe now we can we we want to set this thing up by simulating different different speeds
of the of the of the typesetter and different amount of of internal memory inside the typesetter.
So we can we can find out. So we can sort of shut off the hearing sticks here.
We can say that the types there doesn't have any time to preload characters at all.
How many page false you get then or how many character faults do you get them?
Or what if you have infinite memory? And, you know, all the various different different things could happen.
And so I. So so I my table here, which is described, there is a very different conditions on on how much lookahead you you,
you, you have time to do like L Infinity mentioned in infant.
Look ahead. L zero main means no. Look I had no prepays thing and.
And so then we count how many times when we did this figure, how many times we had a character fault and had to stop and wait.
Falck means that that was the character that it needs for this line is not present inside the memory.
So you have to go in and what you have to go to the end of the line and then come back and do it and then load some our characters in and do it again.
So what it is actually what the. Yeah. So it's that, it's, you know, it's kind of it was how hard to explain the effectiveness of the algorithm.
But my best solution to this was to try to present, you know, by some numerical table that would then and then discuss it afterwards.
But then I put an asterisk in here saying anomalous values that are surprisingly low, some for some reason I would have expected like here,
if we if we increase the memory, we should we should not also increase the number of false.
That's an I mean, somehow having more room should should be better.
But it's the people who who work with with these parallel these these algorithms know that sometimes you can that you get this monetary system.
He goes the other way. You you have more processors and you can.
And it takes longer to run a job because you make a bad mistake in the beginning of something like this.
And in this case, we have a situation where the characters have variable size.
And so you've got not only. You don't only have 100 characters, but you have to fit them in into slots.
And the might we might not work nicely if if, if if they come in a certain order.
Things like this are complicated anyway.
Now what the main thing I did in order to describe the algorithm was the question was to typeset this diagram and this diagram was typeset as.
And it shows the the actual behavior of the algorithm. There are two main main ideas in the look ahead procedure.
And I don't want to dwell on on on it.
But essentially, the farther you are here, the more lines you are ahead.
So so your memory is loaded up until I mean, I think this line coming down here is it's consuming characters in this line below.
It is is loading characters.
And it's when those lines come together, you get a fault because you haven't been able to preload them fast enough for the consumer.
And so you try to get ahead as much as you can by taking a look at the beginning of a page.
You have you have memories or are moving to a moving part of the film.
And so you've got time to load up enough characters to get all of the going to get you started.
And then you try to. So you have a little time to to load more in and.
And so this is what this diagram was. It was then based on on, you know, computer outputs, the details of how the algorithm performed.
And then I could typeset a diagram by typesetting little lines. And also then I would then showing where we are in the quote in that in that sample.
Like you say, exercises or, you know, when you go to exercises, that's where that's that's where the horizontal line is here.
We're going to get to this part which says exercises.
So so you can tell that's the idea. This this diagram.
And so I guess the moral of all of it is that now with with the computer type setting tools that we have,
we can make accurate figures that would be unthinkable.
Know we would have cost a fortune to get such a figure done and you would never have the patients to get the data and do it right before.
So now we could we could hook up the algorithm to the to to the typesetting
system and actually give some some kind of a pictorial output of the algorithm.
And there's many more examples of this can be coming. Thought of. So then so, so giving giving some kind of a snapshot picture,
some kind of a way of visualizing the algorithm is each algorithm has its own specific problems.
But you look at it enough examples, you begin to you could get a feeling.
I'll show you on on Wednesday.
An example of exactly how not to do it was the first paper that I published in the communications of the ACM.
It's my second publication. My first publication was in Mad magazine.
But that's that was different. I didn't draw the figures for that. But this one but this one example of the wrong way to do it.
And then I want to show a couple of more examples of this idea of trying to give a description of an algorithm by what you call it,
play by play or snapshots. And anybody else has better ideas.
They're always they're always welcome. This a tough.
Excuse me. You want to see my first publication? OK. I'll bring the first publication.